a man called william burns
is joe biden's nominee to lead the cia
and we're now learning just like the
biden family itself
that burns has ties to china and its
communist government
the nominee to run the cia fox's trace
gallagher has details in that story
tonight hey trace
hey tucker william burns is a former
deputy secretary of state and u.s
ambassador to russia in 2014 he left
government
to lead the carnegie endowment for
international peace a very influential
u.s think tank that has close ties to
china in fact
one of carnegie's global centers is
based in beijing
and during his time as president of
carnegie william burns
brought in chinese businessman zhang yi
chen to join the board of trustees zhang
is a wealthy chinese investor and member
of two organizations
linked to the chinese communist party
according to the daily caller news
foundation between july of 2017
and the end of 2020 zhang donated
between 750
000 to 1.5 million dollars to carnegie
the think tank says the donations do not
support research projects in the u.s
but some say it's not the money it's the
influence because while burns was at
carnegie it also received donations from
the china united states exchange
foundation or cscu
scf which is a hong kong based think
tank but a global research firm led by
former intel officials from the u.s
says that c-u-s-e-s lobbying activities
in the u.s quoting here
allows it to play a valuable role in
beijing's efforts
to sway public opinion and build
influence in america
and all of this is why republicans have
repeatedly questioned
whether joe biden will confront china
for its human rights abuses and
unfair trade practices or allow china
to keep cheating tucker unbelievable
trace gallagher thanks so much